- So you and I have met before,
and I am very excited to
show the world this picture,
because you and I look
like babies. (laughing)
- Okay, so we have
- Look at these two children!
- Oh my goodness.
- I mean, it's amazing!
- Okay, so
- Where was this?
- So this is at the Dallas Airport,
so we're both from Texas. DFW.
- DF dubs, okay.
We're flying on American to New York.
- Yep, sounds about right.
- This was like a couple
of days after you won Idol.
- Okay.
- And it was a huge deal for
me to see you, as it is now,
because you know,
I would pick up my flip phone
every night and vote for you.
So you're sitting on the
plane and my mom's like,
"We have to talk to
her" and I'm like, Mom,
that's so embarrassing.
Like, let's not like,
bless her heart.
She's newly famous.
She just wants to ride on the plane to go,
probably do the Today Show,
- I was probably half awake. (laughing)
- And you and your bucket
hat were on the plane!
- That bucket hat, I was just
talking about it in the thing.
I was like that hat I
wore that bucket hat out.
- And honestly, its back-
- You want to bring that
on to Project Runway?
- Absolutely, it's back in
a huge way, you were first,
- I am a trend setter.
- Always a trailblazer, always.
- Pioneer, Brandon, that's what I am.